you you play lots of instruments but am
i right you've learned
a new instrument in life yes i did um
a couple of things yeah i learned a
couple of instruments i i sort of really
got to grips with the didgeridoo
and um i um are you serious do you want
to
do it i don't to did we do and um uh i
got a lot of complaints actually from
neighbours
um people thought there was a swarm of
bees uh
but um i i actually also talked i've
been teaching myself this instrument
here
which is um uh it's it's something i've
i've wanted to play for a long time i
play occasionally you know
um but it's it's a mandola and it's like
a mandolin
but it's a deeper sound it makes a
lovely sort of like
a deeper sound i'll give you a little oh
yeah i'll give you a demo
oh yeah um i've written actually i've
been practicing with irish real so i
don't know
if you uh this brings back any memories
i'll chat i'll start
our feet
do
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
oh something like that oh my dad would
have loved you you'd have gotten right
through the door
irish chick don't come in